مرحباً بوزير الخارجية في البرنامج،
أشكركم على استضافتي، وزير الخارجية
الفلسطيني المصاب مزدوجي الجنسية،
بما في ذلك الكثير من الأمريكيين، الذين
يخرجون ونحن نتفهم أن هذا بسبب
المناقشات بين مصر وحماس
وإسرائيل وأعتقد أنك تعرف
الكثير من الناس.  أي نوع من العهد
لديكم لحماس حسنا لدينا أه
خطوط اتصالات موجودة منذ
فترة طويلة والتي استلزمها
الاتفاق بيننا وبين إسرائيل للحفاظ على
الحوار ولعب دورنا
في خلق الهدوء والسكينة عندما
يندلع العنف  اندلعت في
عدة مناسبات خلال هذه
السنوات الأخيرة عامي 214 و 28 وفي تلك
المناسبات حافظنا على تلك
الاتصالات لنتمكن من التدخل ولنتمكن من
التوصل إلى اتفاقات بين
حماس وإسرائيل على نقطة أه أه
التصعيد أه لذلك نحن  استغلال
تلك السياقات الآن لنتمكن من الحصول على
اتفاق أه بشأن خروج مواطني الطرف الثالث
أه بالتأكيد كان هناك
الكثير ممن شاركوا ولكن في
المقام الأول كانت الولايات المتحدة
وأه وأه قدرتها على إجراء
هذه المناقشات والتنسيق  مع
الإسرائيليين، لعب الكاري أيضًا
دورًا إيجابيًا للغاية. هل يمكنني أن أطرح عليك
سؤالاً مختلفًا ولكن ربط العديد من
الجرحى الفلسطينيين الذين
يخرجون الآن، حيث
تقترح وثيقة مسربة من وزارة الاستخبارات الإسرائيلية
نقل جميع
السكان المدنيين في غزة أولاً إلى جنوب غزة.
غزة ومن ثم إلى مصر إلى
شمال
الصين تقول سي إن إن أن هذا جزء من خطة يتم
من خلالها بناء مدن خيام، وسيتم
بناء المزيد من المدن الدائمة
في وقت لاحق على الرغم من أن نتنياهو
قلل من أهمية هذا قائلا إنها مجرد فكرة
أولية، هل سمعت عن
هذا؟  لقد تحدثت مع إسرائيل حول
هذه الخطة بالكاد أه لا أعتقد أننا سوف
أه أي شخص سيطرح مثل هذا
الاقتراح السخيف إذا كان الأمر كذلك ربما
ستفكر الولايات المتحدة أيضًا
أه في توفير نفس الوصول أه إلى
حدودها الجنوبية التي قد تكون  المتوقع
بالنسبة لنا في
سيناء أن الدول ذات سيادة
وهي محددة جيدا بحدودها
المحددة جيدا من قبل سكانها ومسألة
النزوح في حد ذاتها أمر
مخالف للقانون الدولي الإنساني
لذلك أعتقد أنه لا أحد  سوف اه
القيام بنشاط غير قانوني